2018 so towards the end of that year
Trump tweeted a federal judge throws out
Stormy Daniels lawsuit versus Trump
Trump's entitled to full legal fees
great he says now I can go after horse
face and her third-rate lawyer in the
great state of Texas please tell me
you're going to read one of my favorites
she will confirm a letter she's signed
she knows nothing about it a total calm
how did you feel about being called
horse face by the president of the
United States
I laughed my ass off first of all you
could say a lot of things by the way
like I don't actually look like a horse
and if I did I happen to love horses
exactly they're beautiful but
ha
my response just sums up exactly like
like how do you
what did you say
Well Bread is basically our president of
the United States ladies and gentlemen
out into the world he has a pension for
bestiality because this is a guy who
chased me for sex repeatedly and then
says I look like a horse face like